[Applause]
James Bond look yeah it's a little a
little pink a little fuchsia I like it I
like it very much and of course it's a
welcome back to all of you oh that's the
only person dressed
it's beautiful I got Wings on my jacket
it's gorgeous it's embroidered it's
gorgeous can't believe you didn't
mention my wings
Jody you look lovely as well lovely Jody
yes yeah now did you guys uh all chat
backstage of course we did and were you
okay with uh Jody's accent
I love the accent but could you
understand that yeah can you understand
it no I didn't understand
I understand one word that we said you
laughed three times yeah well that's
that's a sign of discomfort
because
dirty figure went to America and Jody
was on uh The Late Show with Stephen
Colbert and a lovely time checked away
Stephen asked the question you answered
them the person who does the subtitles I
feel wasn't really Following the show uh
this is what they wrote
no there's nowhere called
it's a real place where are you from
Huddersfield
[Applause]
Huddersfield beautiful
someone went to drama school
classically trained and I would say I'd
love to have you back Kevin stay well
and thank you healthy and Brilliant very
very good fresh off a trip from
Huddersfield
foreign
[Music]